[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلوها بابره
العلويه
السلطات الامريكيه تستبعد فرضيه الهجوم
السيبراني وقف اكبر مؤقت لحركه الطيران في
البلاد
على واقع اشتداد المعارك في سوليدار موسكو
تغيروا قائد عملياتها واوروبا تتحضر لحرب
طويله الامل
طهران تحكم باعدام مسؤول عسكري بتهمه
التجسس البريطانيا والاخيره تطالبها
بالتراجع والافراج عنه فورا
مقابل الدولار الجنيه المصري 29
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من الحدث الابرز لليوم
اذ انهت اداره الطيران الامريكيه لعمل
بقرار وقف اقلاع الرحلات الجويه على مستوى
البلاد واعلنت عوده تدريجيه لحركه الملاحه
وذلك بعد ساعتين من توقف الطيران المدني
وتعليق والغاء الاف الرحلات الداخليه
المغادره في الولايات المتحده لاصلاح عطل
طرا على انظمتها الرئيس الامريكي وفي رده
على سؤال عن سبب العطل الذي اربح حركه
الطيران في الولايات المتحده قال بايدو ان
السلطات لا تعرف لكن هو امر بالتحقيق
بالسبب
تحدثت وزير النقل الامريكي لا يعرف السبب
حتى الان ولكنني تحدثت معه على الهاتف
لمده 10 دقائق واخبرتها ان يعلمني بكل
تطورات لازال بامكان الطائرات الوجود كمان
لكنهم لا يستطيعون الاقلاع اتوقع انه في
غضونه بضع ساعات سيكون لدينا فكره جيده عن
سبب التعطيل
اذا مشاهدينا كانت حركه الطيران قد توقفت
بشكل تام فوق الاجواء الامريكيه بسبب عطل
فني تقني لم يحدد مصدر وقالت شبكه سنان
الامريكيه ان العطله التقنيه تسبب في
تاجيل اكثر من 10,000 رحله والغاء نحو 750
مع توقف مؤقت لحركه طيران في الولايات
المتحده واسرى توقف حركه الطيران في
الولايات المتحده اثر على الرحلات الجويه
في العالم ايضا حيث اعلنت مطارات باريس ان
جميع رحلات شركات الطيران الامريكيه
ستتاخر حتى اشعار اخر هذا غير ان الخسائر
الماديه التي قدرت بالمليارات في انتظار
الارقام الاكيده حول هذه الخسائر كل هذا
تاخير مشاهدينا كان سببه نظام هو اختصار
لنوته وهو ما يعني تنبيه او اشعارات مهمات
الطائرات ويوفر لشركات الطيران وايضا
للمطارات معلومات السلامه بشكل لحظي
للتخطي للرحلات الجويه ويمتلك امر التوجيه
للطائره بدون اشاره منه لتصبح الطائره
عمياء في الجو ولا تعرف وجهتها وهناك
مشاهدينا نسختان لهذا النظام نسخه عسكريه
واخرى مدنيه مختلفتين عن بعضهما تتضمن
نودلز العسكريه مخاوف تتعلق بالسلامه
محدده للمطارات العسكريه والعمليات
العسكريه واليكم مزيد من التفاصيل عن هذا
النظام
[موسيقى]
انا الان موجوده في مطار رونالد ريجن
المحامي للعاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن عندما
اتينا في ساعات الصباح الاولى كان هناك
عدد من الطائرات متوقف على المدرج ولكن مع
الساعه التاسعه صباحا بدات هذه الطائرات
بالاقلاع ولكن مازلنا نشاهد ان هناك تاخير
بسبب اعاده جدوله الرحلات
تم الغائها واخرى تم تاجيلها وهناك رحلات
ما زالت على موعدها بسمها الرحلات التي
تقوم بعد الظهر بالنسبه للمسافرين عبر عن
انزعاجهم بطبيعه الحال ولكن كما نرى انهم
ما زالوا يحاولون الحصول على تذاكر او
تعديل رحلاتهم الجويه الى الوجهات التي
سيذهبون اليها
تنضم الينا من مطار دالاس في فرجينيا
ناديا البلبيسي مراسله العربيه ناديه كيف
هي الصوره من هناك بعد يعني هذا النهار
العصيب على الولايات المتحده وبعد عوده
حركه طيران الى طبيعتها
ناديه نحن لا نسمعك الان على ما يبدو هناك
مشكلات تقنيه بالصوت
الان هل تسمعينني
حط اللحظه لاني اسمعك ناديه على كل حال
اذكر مشاهدينا بان هذا العطل التقني الذي
ضرب كل مطارات الولايات المتحده عادت
الينا ناديه
كنت اتحدث عن استئناف حركات الطيران بشكل
عام الهبوط والاقلاع كما ترينا هنا على
هذه اللائحه في مطار دالاس كل ما هو
باللون الاصفر هو اما تاجيل او اعاده
جدوله لهذه الرحلات وايضا هناك رحلات
بالاحمر الغيت تماما معها منها رحلات
داخليه ورحلات اوروبيه همم الحظ هنا رحلات
من المانيا لكن بشكل عام اا كما تحدثنا
منذ ساعات الصباح هناك عمليه استئناف
كامله لعوده هذه الرحلات لكن المشكله
الاساسيه هي ماذا سيحدث بكل المسافرين
الذين ينتظرون منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
حتى الان طبعا نستطيع ان نقول بان
المسافرين بشكل عام معتدين على التاخير في
المطارات الامريكيه لانه بالفعل هذا هو
الحال سواء كان بسبب الاحوال الجويه او
بسبب ازمه كوفي في السابق لكن لم نرى هذا
الحجم من الغاء والتعطيل
ما رايناه اليوم طبعا هناك مساءلات
مساءلات سياسيه وقبل قليل تحدث وزير
المواصلات بو دجاج وقال بانه سيكون هناك
تحقيق شامل لما حدث اليوم طبعا استبعد مره
اخرى كما ذكرت ان يكون هناك هجوم سبراني
لكن على الاقل ذكر مره اخرى ما تحدثت عنه
في نشرات الصباح بانه ربما وكان اجراء
احترازي ايضا بمعنى بانه هذه المعلومات
التي تصل من
الكمبيوتر الاساسي او المركزي لكل
الطيارين عبر التيارات الولايات المتحده
في الاجواء الامريكيه تعطل وبالتالي
كاشراء احترازهم الذين اوقفوا كل حركه
الطيران حتى لا يكون هناك حوادث لكن ما هو
سبب هذا العطل الفني لاحد حتى الان يستطيع
ان يؤكد سواء كان وزاره المواصلات او
البيت الابيض او مسؤولين الملاحه الجويه
طبعا لاحدا يعرف ماذا حدث لكن سيكون هناك
مساء الا سيكون تحقيق سيكون هناك جلسات
خصوصا من بطلب من الجمهوريين لوزير
المواصلات والمسؤولين في اداره الرئيس
بايدن همم كيف يمكن لدوله بحجم الولايات
المتحده هذه الدوله التي تقود العالم
تتعطل فيها حركه الملاحه بهذه الدرجه على
مدى ساعتين هذا هو سؤال سيوجه للعديد من
المسؤولين الامريكيين البعض يرى بان
المطارات الامريكيه غير مؤهله اصلا لم يكن
فيها عمليات تحديث ليس فقط بالمباني
والابراج المراقبه
والمدرجات لكن ايضا في نظام الالكتروني
الذي يربط الولايات المتحده واللاتي كنا
نقول من البدايه انها بحجم قاره يعني
السفر ما بين واشنطن فرنسيسكو يسرق تسع
سنوات ههه
كانك مسافره الى بلد اوروبي
ومع التاخير ومع الحاصل الان ممكن ان تاخذ
اكثر ناديه يعني عدا الحديث عن مكانها
يتحدث عنه الرئيس ترامب همم يعني بحماته
الانتخابيه قبل عن موضوع تحديث المطارات
ولماذا مطارات الولايات المتحده اصبحت
يعني متراجعه نسبه للمطارات بالخليج
العربي مترات بدول اخرى هل ممكن اعاده فتح
هذا الملف هل ممكن اخذ خطوات عمليه فيه
اوه بالتاكيد هذا بالفعل ما كان يركز عليه
ترامب في كل خطاء حديث انتخابي او في
مهرجان انتخابي وليس فقط الانتقاد بانه
طبعا الولايات المتحده نظام فيراري صعب
للحكومه الفيدراليه في واشنطن ان تمرن
المشاريع او تجبر الولايات ان يقوموا بعمل
تحديث مالي مطار ما لكن الان اعتقد بانه
سيكون هناك مراجعه كبيره لكن ال- المشكله
الاساسيه فقط في التحديث اللي هو غير لا
يواكب التطور
التكنولوجي الذي تعيش الولايات المتحده
وتقود العالم في لكن ايضا هناك اتهامات
قبل قليل كنت اتابع كل ردود الفعل من
الجمهوريين ومن محسوبين على الجمهوريين
الذين يقولون بان مشكله الاداره
الديمقراطيه بانها تقوم بتوظيف الاشخاص
الغير ملائمين لاداره ربما مرافق حيويه
مثل المطرات على اساس العداله الاجتماعيه
وعلى اساس توظيف الاقليات والغيره على
حساب الكفاءه هذا ما يقصدوه طبعا هل هو
صحيح او صحيح طبعا
للخلافيه وسيتم الحديث فيها ناديه لو سمحت
يعني خلال هذه الرساله هل ممكن ان نرى
حركه المسافرين خلفك بالصوره همم يعني همم
عندما تشرحين ما يحدث هناك
اكيد
اكيد لو سمحت احمد الان طبعا في المطار
لانه كما تعرفين همم الطائرات تهبط وتقلى
حسب جدول وبالتالي بسبب التاخير احيانا
نرى طائره تهبط وفيها مئات من المسافرين
ان اتحدث مع مسافرين انتم
مسافرين انتم من اثيوبيا ومن قطر همم
رحلات الخارجيه لم تتاثر كثيرا رحلات
الداخليه كلها تاثرت لكن سالتهم هل يشعرون
بالقلق او بعدم الرضا قالوا بانه متعودين
بشكل عام لان كما قلت لك هناك هناك تاخير
دوما يصاحب كل الرحلات في داخل الولايات
المتحده لكن الحركه بسيطه الان احيانا
تخاف احيانا تزيد حسب جدول وصول الطائرات
لكن طبعا على ما دار اليوم نستطيع ان نقول
بان هناك استئناف كامل لعوده الرحلات في
كل المطارات الامريكيه لكن المشكله الاساس
ماذا سيحدث بكل المسافرين الذين انتظروا
على مدى ساعتين البعض تاجل انتم تماما
لساعات البعض التغت هذه الرحله وبالتالي
ستضطر شركات الطيران التعامل مع هذا الوضع
الذي عانت منه الساعه في همم
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث الان ليس فقط خسائر
لاين نعم نتحدث عن ليس فقط خسائر بالسياسه
وانما ايضا خسائر بالاقتصاد يعني ليس ما
نعلم الارقام الحقيقيه لخسائر اليوم شكرا
لك ناديه البلبيسي على هذه الرساله وعلى
الرسائل طيله هذا النهار من مطار دنس
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من سان دييغو الدكتور
صلاح فتيح الخبير في شؤون الفضاء والطيران
دكتور صلاح يعني ما حدث اليوم بالولايات
المتحده كيف يمكن تفسيره هذا العطل الذي
طرا وباكبر قوه اقتصاديه واكبر قوه
تكنولوجيه عالميه كيف يمكن تفسيره
لقناه العربيه وللمستمعين على الاستضافه
همم لازم نتذكر ان كل هذه الامور ترجع في
النهايه الى الكمبيوتر همم
كمبيوتر
همم المشكلتين اللي احنا شفناهم في
الاسبوع اللي فات لاينز والنهارده
كان في مشاكل عندهم في الكمبيوتر وصفت وير
المسؤول عن
انفورميشن سيستم ودي اشياء همم يعني همم
طبيعيه طبيعيه
لكن بتحصل من وقت الى اخر المره دي لمست
شيء مهم في حركه الطيران في امريكا اسمها
نقطه نقطه
الفضاء الامريكيه ايه فرضت على كل الشركات
الطيران او الطيارين انه لابد ان هم
يدخلوا على النظام ده ويشوفوا اذا كان في
معلومات جديده عن المسار بتاعهم او من
مطار اللي هينزلوا فيه والراند واي
والحاجات دي يبقوا عارفينها قبل ما
يتحركوا فلما النظام بروك او كسر او يعني
مش ما اشتغلش صحيح
التعليمات كل الطائرات ما حدش يطلع
الكلام ده
كما ذكرته وكما ذكر البيت الابيض في
البيان وكل التقرير ولكن هل يوم وضع يعني
المطارات الامريكيه
نسب والتحديث التكنولوجي الذي وصلت اليه
الولايات المتحده
التحديث التكنولوجيا بدا من 20 سنه ومستمر
وهيستمر خلاص لكن انظروت على الطريق في
التحديث هتحصل هكر بنسميها يعني العربي
زغطه يعني اسماعيل ههه
بيحصل اخطاء هنا وهنا فده شيء يعني همم مش
غريب بس ان شاء الله ما يكونش كثير همم
النقطه الاضافيه اللي عايز اضيفها ان
النقطه اللي هو الخلل اللي حصل في لا يؤثر
في الطياره ولا الطيران لكن بيؤثر في
البروسيجر اجراءات الطيران اللي هي ايه
ايه هي المسؤوله عن الناس يعني الطيران
همم الطيران ال- ال- المساحات الطيران
اللي موجوده في امريكا تملك ايه وحاطه
قواعد عشان الطيارات تطلع فمن ضمن القواعد
الدين قبل الطائره ما تطلع لو غده التيار
يخش على النقطه يشوف احدث معلومات ايه
وبعدين عشان النهارده
ما حدش من الطيارين كان قادر يخش على
المعلومات هي ايه اللي بتقول له مثلا
المطار اللي هينزل في مشكله او المسار
بتاع الطياره نقطه الاصول فيها مشكله او
في مشاكل
قرار انا ما حدش يطلع
لكن الطائرات الطائرات مهيئه ممكن تطلع
لكن
مش هتبقى ملتزمه
بقوانين وقواعد ولوائح اداره الطيران
الامريكيه الفيدراليه
طبعا لا شيء يمنع من هذا يعني ممكن تحصل
ثاني ان شاء الله ما تحصلش لكن ممكن تحصل
ثاني ليه لان دي عندك كمبيوتر
او في السوفت وير او في الداتا اللي هي
دخلت على الكمبيوتر تخزينه وتستعمل بعد
كده ف- اا يعني ما حدش يقدر يجزم لان مش
هتحصل ثاني طبعا هيبقى في محاولات يشوفوا
الخلل حصل فين وازاي وتصلح وتضبط طبعا ده
هيتم
بالطيران السويسري
السويسري
ولا سوسو من اسبوع
ليس لديك معلومات عنه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك يا دكتور صلاح الخبير في شؤون
الفضاء
[موسيقى]
تتابعونا مشاهدينا في التاسعه و لكن بعد
قليل
بعد وصفهالمه نقابات العمال في بريطانيا
ترفض خطط الحكومه لاعاده النظر في الاجور
[موسيقى]
القسطره القلبيه العلاجيه
وجراحات القلب
المواساه خبره تنبض بالثقه
اليوم رخاء وتطور وضعها على خريطه الدول
الاولى
لكن المنطقه التي نعيش فيها مليئه
بالشراحات تهديدات اقليميه من دول اخرى
منظمات ارهابيه وجماعات المسلحه
النمو في اهل واحد
تواجهها هذه الدول وهذه المجتمعات هل يمكن
المضيق قدما في مساء التنميه دون تفتيك
الالغام الثقافيه وبنائي ذهنيه الحاضنه
للتنميه في كل مجالات اهم الموضوعات
المتعلقه بالشكل الخليجي مع ابرز المحللين
والمختصرين
هذا البرنامج يحاول صحبه ثله من المعنيين
ارتياده هذا الطريق الصعب
الديدي السبت ال3:30 على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
يتحول باستمرار
الرياض من 20 الى 21 فبراير
من دول العالم يجتمعون في المنتدى السعودي
للاعلام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بين تاكيد مرتزقه فاجنر
ونفي الجيش الاوكراني للسيطره على فوليدار
تستمر المعارك العنيفه لبل اكثر دمويه منذ
حرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
التي شددت على ان قواتها موجوده داخل
سوليدار الاستراتيجيه ومازال تقاوم الهجوم
الروسيه وبينما 9 موسكو بقواتها ومواليها
لحصار باخمد بشكل كامل وفي اقرب وقت اعلن
الاتحاد الاوروبي انه يستعد لحرب طويله
الامد في اوكرانيا لا بل ستزيد من
العقوبات على روسيا
تهاجم اوكرانيا
المحتله في اوكرانيا
وسنقوم بتدمير كامل البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه للجيش الروسي في الاراضي المحتله
بما في ذلك بما في ذلك شبه جزيره القرم
الامر الثاني
[موسيقى]
الاصرار الروسيه على اخضع بلده فوليدار
الصغيره الواقعه شمال شرقي اوكرانيا اثار
تساؤلات حول اهميه هذه المدينه فسوليدار
اصغر من داخل
حوالي ثلاث مرات ولا يتجاوز عدد السكان
فيها العشره الاف نسمه الى ان مغريات عده
تقف خلف تماسك روسيا بها اولها يتمثل بكون
بخموت محطه وصول بكون هذه المدينه محطه
الوصول الى باخمود التي تبعد 15 كلم عنها
تلالها المرتفعه تعطيها ميزه الاشراف على
خطوط الامداد الاستراتيجيه بين منطقتي
لوغانسك ودنياسك في اقليم
من الشمال اسهل بكثير وبال تعطيل خطوط
الامداد والتواصل الاوكرانيه هذا بدوره من
شانه ان يخرق خط الدفاع الرئيسي لاوكرانيا
في دومباز ويفتح الطريق امام تقدم روسي في
مدن رئيسيه كبرى جنوب مقاطعه دنيا مثل
الكراماتوس وسلوفيانس كما ان ارتياح
القوات الروسيه في المحور الشمالي يجعل
العوده نحو
لمانوبيانس في المثلث الساخن حول طريق
الزفاتف السبات اوفوفو بين مقاطعه حركات
ودنياسك ورمان ممكنه سببا اخر مشاهدينا
جعل من سوليدار محط انظار الروس وفق رئيس
مجموعه فاجنر وهو احتوائها لانفاق تعدين
ممتده تحت الارض هذه الانفاق تمتد الى
اكثر من 100 و60 كلم قادر على اتساع جنود
ودبابات وعربيات موشات قتاليه مع قدرتها
على التحرك فيها بحريه ومن ضمن
المطبعه مع الروسيه في سوليدار السيطره
على مناجم الملح الكبيره في هذه المنطقه
المعارك في بلده سوليدار الاوكرانيه
متوسطه بين الجيش الاوكراني والجيش الروسي
الذي يحاول تحقيق اول اختراق في ميدان
المعركه منذ سته اشهر وفي ما تنفي
اوكرانيا ان تكون المدينه قد سقطت في ايدي
مجموعه مرتزقه فاجنر دعا الكريملين الى
عدم التسرع في اعلان الانتصار في المدينه
باستخدام مرتزقه روسيا لاحكام السيطره على
مدينه سولدار تمهيدا لتطبيق مدينه باخمه
الاستراتيجيه ومن ثم فتح الطريق امام
الجيش الروسي للوصول الى المدن الكبرى في
منطقتي دون يسكن
وهنا يواجه الجيش الاوكراني هجمات
المتعدده على البلده الواقعه
والتي باتت اكثر النقاط سخونه على جبهه
المعارك في اوكرانيا
لمواصله لمساعده الاوكرانيين انهم قاتلون
من اجل حريتنا ايضا
الصمود في وجه الاله العسكريه الروسيه
التي تحاول دفع القوات الاوكرانيه
للانسحاب الى جيوب البلده من الجهه
الغربيه لا يزال متواصلا رغم قصف الطريق
السريع الذي يرسل الامدادات العسكريه
للمنطقه وضرب كل نقاط الاتصال بين القياده
والجنود في ذات الوقت تتجه كتائب من
القوات الخاصه الروسيه لناحيه الشماليه
نحو مدينه السيفرسك التي تتمركز فيها قوات
الاوكرانيه والواقعه بين الاستشاست في
لوكا وسوليدار من اجل السيطره على المحور
الشمالي باكمله من دنياك في المرحله
المقبله
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من دنيا قراءه
الاخبار مراسل العربيه ومن موسكو عبد
الجواد الرشد بوراس العربيه سابدا معك
رائد السيطره على سوليدار واحراز تقدم في
المناطق الشرقيه والشماليه كيف هي الصوره
من هناك
تجري عمليات تنشيط وتطهير لكل المدينه
طبعا هناك سبا كبير في التصريحات حيث كما
اسلفت اعلن لكريم عدم العجله في
اصدار
رائد يعني هناك تقطع بالصوت ساعود اليك
فورا
جهودك من جديد انتقل الان الى عبد جواد
الرشد عبد جواد هناك روايتين متناقدتين
اليوم بين الجانب الروسي ومن الجانب
الاوكراني بموضوع هذه المنطقه والسيطره
عليها ما هي الروايه الروسيه من هناك
مساء الخير ليال لكي ولي رائد في البدايه
اسمحي لي ان اتحدث عن هذا الخبر العاجل
والذي بداه الزميل لرائد بان يعني قائد او
مؤسس مجموعه افاغناري يتحدث للتو بان
سوليدار بالكامل الان اصبحت تحت سيطره
القوات الروسيه وتجري الان هناك عمليه
تمشيط لكافيتش شوارع المدينه اعداد القتلى
بين عناصر الجيش الاوكراني وصلوا قرابه
500 والكثير منهم طبعا قاموا بتسليم
انفسهم كاسرى من لم من لم يرغب باليس
بعمليه الاستسلام يعني تم قتله كما يتحدث
البيان عن يفقد وهو مؤسس مجموعه
طبعا ليال يعني الروايه الروسيه حتى هذه
اللحظه فيها تضارب في المعلومات ان كانت
على لسان القوات التي تقوم بهذه العمليات
هناك او الكرملين لان الذي تحدث اليوم
بانه لن يستعجل بالحكم حول على التقا
الوارده من هناك ولابد من انتظار التقارير
الرسميه والتي يعتمد عليها من وزاره
الدفاع طبعا وزاره الدفاع موسكو تحدثت
اليوم عن ان سوليدار اصبحت الان بين فكي
القوات الروسيه هي تحظى بتطويق من منطقتي
الشمال والجنوب وتجري فيها الان عمليات
يعني تطهير كما يسميها الجانب الروسي
القوات الجويه الروسيه تعمل هناك وتقوم
بضرب نقاط العدو هذا اخر بيان لوزاره
الدفاع لا بد من لفت الانتباه بانه جاء
قبل الاعلان من مؤسس ضاجنار حول السيطره
الكامله ونقطه الاخيره طبعا تحدثت عنها
وزاره الدفاع بان القوه في تلك المنطقه
تقوم قوات الهجوم تقوم بملاحقه فلول
الجنود الاوكرانيين او العدو كما تساميهم
موسكو لذلك طبعا هي مفارقه كبيره
بالتصريحات حولها هذا الموضوع عليها تفضل
عبد الج اسمح لي ان اعود الى زمير رائد
الاخضر رائد الصوره من هناك معك باختصار
لو سمحت
فيها معارك
ضاريه يعني
بتقرير وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التي يؤكد
بان هناك معارك ضاريه وسط المدينه حتى
الان وفي المنطقه الغربيه لكن الاله
العسكريه الثقيله المدفعيه الروسيه
مهرجانات الصواريخ تقصد تلك المنطقه لكن
هناك مصادر على الطرف الاخر تشير الى
اندادات عسكريه وصلت لتحصل او تقوي خط
الدفاع الاوكراني في المحور الغربي
خاصه في المحور الغربي من المدينه لكن
القوات الروسيه بكل الاحوال همم
من السيطره على المدينه كلها حتى ولو
سيطرت كما قال قالت فهذا يعني بان هناك
عمليات تنظيم او تطبيق الذي التي مازلت
متواجده في اطراف المدينه الغربيه لكن
الاهم من ذلك كله مع السيطره على مدينه
سنديدار اصبحت مدينه
في الناحيه ال الجنوبيه من سيليدار وتيبر
في المنطقه الشماليه من سيلدار بمرمى
القوات الروسيه كما اسلابتي ان هنا انها
منطقه تحظى بالمرتفعات يعني التضاريس هناك
مرتفعات وهضبات تساعد القوات الروسيه على
قصف مراكز يعني تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه
للسيطره بسهوله والدخول البريدي يكون اسهل
على المقاتلين الروس وايضا الجانب الاخر
الشمس يعني
خطاب على منطقه سيفر سيكون اسهل بكثير لان
ايضا تطبيق للمدينه من الجنوب والشمال
والشرق كما هو الحال في بطنه شكرا لكما
مراسيلي العربيه رائد الاخبار من دنياسكو
ومن موسكو عبد الجواد الرست على هذه
الرسائل
اقر وزير الدفاع الروسيه تعديلات في
المناصب العسكريه لعدد من الضباط الروس
واجره عينات جديده في قياده العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا حيث اعلن عن
تعيين رئيس الاركان العامه فاليري جرسيموف
قائدا جديدا للقوات الروسيه المشاركه في
العمليه العسكريه باكرانيا
هذا واكد صحيفه واشنطن بوست انا مجموعه
فاجن الروسيه اصدرت اعفاءات المشندين
الذين جمعتهم من السجون الروسيه وعدد
هؤلاء نحو 40 الف مدان واضافت ان مؤسس
المجموعه قدم للمجندين رواتب مغريه وعفوا
بشرط ان يخدموا نصف عام كجزء من قوات
الصدمه ووحدات المشاه ونقلت عن عائلات
السجناء السابقين ان العفو تم توقيعه خلال
اوائل يوليو بحسب الصحيفه الامريكيه مئات
العشرات من المدنيين الذين شكلوا دفعه
التجنيد الاولى قتلوا على جبهات القتال
فيما عاد العشرات منهم الى ديارهم بعد
استكمال فتره السته اشهر ورجعت واشنطن
بوست ان يعاد ارسال هؤلاء الافراد الى
الجبهه في غضون اسابيع بعتاد ضعيف وتدريب
قليل او معدوم من جهته رفضها المتحدث باسم
الكرام لن اعطاء اجابه مباشره على تاكيد
العفو السري مضيفا ان العفو
يمكن تنفيذه الا بموجب مرسومه رئاسيه
قبل اقل من عام بدات روسيا عمليتها
العسكريه بدخول اقليم دومباز من الشرق فما
هي ابرز محطات العمليه الروسيه شرقي
اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه وصلت التقدم في
مارس واقتربت من السيطره على اول مدينه
اوكرانيه كبيره شمال شرقي البلاد وهي كما
نشاهد هنا حركات انتصار وصف بالاستراتيجيه
تحقق في شهر مايو بالسيطره على ماريوبل
المطله على بحر از اوف بعد صمود نحو جندي
اوكرانيه داخل مصنع افاستا للصلب لحوالي
الشهر بعد السيطره الروسيه على ماريو بيل
ومدن عده في اقليم دومباز بقيت على الجانب
الاخر في الشرق مدينه
حينها في الثامن والعشرين من مايو تمكن
القوات المواليه لروسيا من السيطره على
مدينه ليمان مركز مهم السكك الحديديه في
منطقه دونياس كما هو معروف في يونيو
الماضي اعلن حاكم لو جانسك سيطرت القوات
الروسيه على مدينه سيبرودونيس
الاستراتيجيه في الثالث من يوليو وبعد
احكام السيطره على سيفردونيس كواليس اعلنت
القوات الروسيه السيطره على منطقه
فيما تبقى امامها منطقه
لاحكام قبضتها على اقليم جمباز باكمله انا
ذاك كما نذكر شهر سبتمبر شهد مشاهدينا
تقدما اوكرانيا شرقي مع السعاده بلدات
رئيسيه بينها ايسيوم في ديسمبر وبدايه
العام الجديد تتركز الجهود الروسيه على
مدينتي سيفرياس وباخمه المجاورهتين
وصالي دار المجاوره هي الطريقه الاقرب
لتحقيق هذه الاهداف
وطبعا كنا ذكرنا
[موسيقى]
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه انها تدعم
عائله علي رضا اكبر والذي صدر بحقه حكم
اعدام اليوم بتهمه التجسس لصالح بريطانيا
كما حدد الخارجيه البريطانيه طهران
الافراج عن علي رضا اكبر والذي كان يعمل
سابقا كمسؤول في وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه
واصفه اكبر بالمواطن البريطاني
اما في ملف الاحتجاجات ومع زياده قمع
القوات الامنيه والانتشار المكثف لها في
الشوارع الايرانيه وقطع الطرقات اضافه الى
الوضع الاقتصادي السيء تعذر على الاف
المحتاجين الايرانيين الوصول لنقاط التجمع
ما دفعها هؤلاء الى تغيير الاستراتيجيه
للتظاهر وتمثلت بتشكيل مجموعات صغيره في
كل حي وحاره على ان تكون خاطفه بمعنى ان
المتظاهرين يخرجون في تظاهرات محدوده
وسريعه لاسيما فتره الليل هتافات وتصوير
ثم العوده للمنازل وقد رصد اسلوب
الاحتجاجات الخاطف هذا في مناطق كرديه
متعدده بينها سلندرش وكذلك العاصمه طاهره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مواقف عندها في اللوازم معي الشيا
للايرانيين وحقوقهم الاساسيه دفعتهم
للشارع مرارا على مدى سنوات طويله وما بدا
في سبتمبر الماضي كاحتجاجات على مقتل
الشاب مهسا امينه والدفاع عن حقوق النساء
تشحدها مظالم اقتصاديه كثيره وفق صحيفه
واشنطن بوست فالعمله المحليه اي الريال
سجل ادنى مستوياتها في ديسمبر مكمله
انهيار كامل امام الدولار شهر ديسمبر شهد
كذلك تجاوز معدل التضخم 48% وهو اعلى
مستوى له منذ اكثر من 25 عاما التاثير
الاوليه لهذا التضخم ينعكس بطبيعه الحال
على معاشه الناس والمكافحه لتغطيه نفقاتهم
وفقا الصحيفه الامريكيه فالاستياء الشعبي
زاده حده ارتفاع التكاليف حتى باتت المواد
الغذائيه الاساسيه مثل اللحوم والبيض هذا
وكان خرجوا بمظاهرات واسعه اواخر عام 2019
احتجاجا طبعا على ارتفاع اسعار الوقود
لكنها انتهت بسقوط اكثر من 1500 قديم
[موسيقى]
بعدما وصفوها بالمهزله التامه يرفض نقابات
العاملين او ترفض نقابات العاملين في
بريطانيا المشاركه في عمليه لاعاده النظر
في الاجور قائله اي النقابات العماليه ان
عمليه اعاده النظر في الاجور ليست مستقله
واعلنت انها لن تمتثل لطلبات الحصول على
ادله لادخالها في الحسابات المتعلقه
بالدفع لعمي 2023 و 2024 قبل ذلك دخل
موظفوا الاسعاف اضرابا اليوم الاربعاء مع
تحذير المواطنين من توقع حدوث تاثيرات في
حال احتاجه لتلقيمات الطوارئ وتطالب
المجموعات العماليه برفع الاجور والحكومه
ترد بضروره الالتزام بالتوصيات طبعا
الوزراء هنا يصلون على انه يجب عليهم
الالتزام بالتوصيات التي قدمتها الهيئه
المسؤوله عن مراجعه اجور العاملين في هيئه
الصحه العامه و وفقا لاحصائيات وارقام
بريطانيه فان نحو 20 الفا عمال وموظفين
اسعاف في كل من انجلترا وويلز مشاركين في
الاضراب المعلل هذا عن العمال اما الحكومه
فقد صعدت المستوى لهجتها ضد العمال سواء
في التمريض او قطاع النقل حتى وصلت مرحله
التهديد بفصل عمال وتعهد رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك بالمضيق قدما في
تطبيق قوانين جديده صارمه للحد من سلطه
النقابات وتقتضي حدا ادنى من موظفي
الاسعاف ورجال الاطفاء والسكك الحديديه
اثناء الاضراب اما وزير الصحه البريطانيه
فااا المواطنين الى استخدامه وصفه
بالمنطقه السليم للتعامل مع اضراب عمال
الاسعاف مشددا على ضروره التعامل مع
الحالات الخطيره فقط
عشره سيارات الاسعاف هذه حول مقر الاسعاف
مركونه وليست في الخدمه بسبب اضراب اطقم
الاسعاف وهذه مجموعه من بين اكثر من 20
الف مسعف على خطوط الاعتصام ليوم واحد بعد
فشل مفاوضات الحكومه مع نقابتهم في
الاتفاق على رفع الاجور
الاف المرضى الغيت مواعيد علاجاتهم غير
الطارئه بسبب الاضراب الذي سيؤدي بحسب
اعتراف النقابه الى المزيد من الاذى
للمرضى فيما تنصح هيئه الصحه باستخدام
خدماتها بحكمه
لقد عمل ممثل خدمه الاسعاف في لندن بجديه
تامه في الاسبوعين الماضيين واجتمعوا مع
ادارتها هيئه الاسعاف لوضع خطه التعامل مع
مكالمات الطوارئ للحصول على رعايه اللازمه
عندما يحتاجونها مثل ما شاهدنا اليوم ترك
مصيف من الصفوف الاعتصام للقيام بذلك
الاتهامات المتبادله بين حزب العمال ورئيس
الحكومه تزايدت مع التوسع الاضرابات وقد
هاجم ريش سوناك حزب العمال لدعمه
الاضرابات في جلسه لمساءله الاسبوعيه
للحكومه
الطوارئ هذه يجب ان يعتمد الناس على حد
ادنى من الرعايه المنقذه للحياه لماذا
يعترض على ذلك
لا يوجد حد ادنى للخدمه لانكم دمرتم قطاع
الصحه
[تصفيق]
اضراب اخر لعمال الاسعاف من جدول في
الثالث والعشرين من الشهر الحالي وقبله
سيتوقف الممرضون عن العمل اليومين الاسبوع
المقبل ومن شان ذلك كله ان يفاقم الاضطراب
غير المسبوق الذي يشهده قطع الصحه
فاجمعنا في بريطانيا على ضروره حل ازمه
الاجور خصوصا بعد جلوس الحكومه مطلع
الاسبوع لاول مره مع قاده النقابات لكنها
اشتراط الحكومه ربه اي زياده بتحصيل
الانتاجيه وتمسكا النقابات بمطالبها سيؤدي
الى مفاهمه الاضطرابات في قطاع الصحه
المنهكي اصلا مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن
ينضم الينا مجددا مصطفى زارو مراسل
العربيه من لندن مصطفى يعني بعد هذا
النقاش الذي احتدم بين كل من السلطات
الرسميه
ونقابه الممرضين ما هي اخر التطورات
بموضوع الاضراب وبموضوع الاتفاق بين
الطرفين
في الحقيقه ليس هناك اي اتفاق لكن هناك
بوادر ايجابيه بان اخيرا الحكومه جلست مع
النقابات لمناقشه ازمه رفع الاجور وايضا
فيما يتعلق
بشروط تسريح العمال وايضا الامن الوظيفي
هذا من جانب لكن من جانب اخر
ربماسه تصعد من هذه الاضرابات خصوصا وان
همم اتحاد همم يعني ان ان نقابه العامه
والتجاريه اعلنت انها ستعزز وستوسع من
اضراباتها في في الايام يعني الاسديه
والاشهر المقبله برده دخل الحكومه على
التعامل مع مطالبه وخاصه في ما يتعلق
بزياده الاجور بسبب غلاء المعيشه الذي لم
يحتمل من قبل العديد من هؤلاء الذين
يقدمون خدمات جديده ك- كالتمريض والاسعاف
همم يعني بالنسبه للاضراب اليوم ل همم
اطقم الاسعاف سينتهي في ساعه 11 من مسائل
اليوم ولكن همم هذا الاضراب لازم تدلي
اثنا عشر ساعه لا نعرف الاضراب المقبل في
الثالث والعشرين ان سيكون لي ساعات محدوده
ام سيكون ليوم كامل ولكن بالطبع سيكون
هناك اجتماع
لانقادات همم يعني خلال هذا الاسبوع
وبدايه الاسبوع المقبل لتحديد همم المده
الزمنيه لهذا الاضرار ولكن بالطبع نحن
مقبلون على مزيد من الاضافي كافه القطاعات
وخاصه التي يعني تعمل همم من اجل الحكومه
هناك ملا يقل عن 100,000 همم موظف مدني
سيضربون في همم الاول من فبراير همم يعني
الشهر المقبل وهذا مؤشر سلبي للغايه يجب
على الحكومه ان تتحرك تقول همم مختلف
النقابات ل همم
حديد يعني همم اموال همم اضافيه لمحاوله
مساعدتها هؤلاء الذين يعانون من كلفه
المعيشه المرتفعه ولكن الحكومه ربما من
خلال اجتماع واحد ربما لم يتم حل كل هذه
المشاكل المتعلقه بالاجور ولكن هناك بوادر
ايجابيه يمكن التواصل الى صيغه معينه
لتلبيه هذه المطالب بشكل او باخر شكرا لك
مصطفى زارو مراسل العربيه حدثنا من لندن
تحقق السلطات البريطانيه في ضبط رجال
الشرطه للحدود بطرد ملوث باليورانيوم في
مطار هيثرو بلاندن وقالت الشرطه انه تم
تحديد كميه صغيره للغايه من المواد
الملوثه بعد فحص الروتيني لطرد ضمن شحنه
معادن خرده وارد الى المملكه المتحده في
التاسع والعشرين من ديسمبر وتحدثت مصادر
عن ان الطرد انطلق من باكستان ووصل الى
هيثرو عبر دوله ثالثه
البريطانيه اثار كان في طريقه الى
ايرانيين في بريطانيا واشارت الشرطه ان
المواد التي تم اكتشافها لا تشكل تهديدا
ولم تسفر تحقيقات حتى اللحظه عن ارتباطها
باي تهديد مباشره
تتابعونا في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
توسعه منجم فحم في المانيا يتسبب بصدامات
بين الشرطه ونشطاء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في مصر تراجعت العمله
المصريه مقابل الدولار الامريكي الى
مستويات تاريخيه مسجله مستوى يزيد عن 32
جنيها للدولار مع انتقال البنك المركزي
الى النظام صرف اكثر مرونه بموجب شروط
حزمه دعم ماليه من صندوق النقد الدولي ومع
نهايه التعاملات اليوم خلص الجنيه بعض
خساره امام الدولار واغلق عند مستوى
29.74 جنيه بحسب متوسط سعر الصرف في
البنوك
تتامل السيده جيهان في اسعار السلع التي
تعتاد على شرائها في الفتره الاخيره تشهد
زياده ملحوظه في الاسعار بشكل يومي
فانخفاض قيمه الجنيه امام الدولار بسبب
التعويم بالاضافه الى عدم توفر سيوله
النقديه من الدولار بسبب تداعيات الحرب
الروسيه الاخرانيه ان عكس بشكل مؤلم على
قطاعات كبيره من المصريين كل واحد حاطط
سعر فعلا وسعر
رهيب يعني انا ممكن اشتري حاجه النهارده
بكره زادت 10 جنيه وبعده زادت 10 جنيه
ثاني هو انا شايفه ان اي حد في باب السعر
اللي هو عايزه ما فيش رقابه على حد بعضه
صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي نشرت مقاطع فيديو
عن نفادي بعض السلعي من المتاجر الكبيره
توجهنا الى احد هذه المتاجر واتضح ان نفاد
السلع كان نتيجه الاقبال المكثف على
العروض المخفضه بسبب الاحتفال بمرور 20
عاما على افتتاح المتجر اسئله او موجوده
ولكن جهه تركز دائما على الاسعار المتغيره
هو حسب ما بيجي المندوب الشركه بيجيء انا
باطل من الشركه بيجيء يقول لي مثلا الحاجه
بكذا بسعر حسب ما يقول الشركه مش مش احنا
كمان يعني بنحط الاسعار طبعا خبراوي
يؤكدونا ان ارتفاع اسعار السلع
الاستهلاكيه لن يحل بشكل النهائي الا من
خلال توفر الفائض من الدولار والغاء السوق
الموازيه التي يستغلها بعض المستوردين
والتجار كذريعه لفرض زياده في الاسعار
بشكل يومي وبالنسب مبالغ فيها جزء من جشع
من التجار طبعا لتخزين السلع ديت لبيعها
باسعار مغاله فيها واسعار اغلى همم طبقا
طبعا لرؤيه ان ان يعني اسعار الدولار
بترتفع بشكل كبير وبيتم تسعير السلع
الغذائيه لسعر الدولار وله مواجهه
التحديات والتخفيف عن كاهل الاسر المصريه
قررت القوات المسلحه طرحه ملايين العبوات
من السلع الغذائيه بنصفي اسعارها في جميع
المحافظات لتبقى تحديات حكومه في قدرتها
على الاستمرار في توفير الجميع السلع وقد
يكون التحدي الاكبر وفي قدرتها على فرض
الرقابه والسيطره على الاسعار التي ترتفع
بشكل غير مضبوط بشكل
باتضاغت على الكثير من الاسر المصريه احمد
عثمان العربيه القاهره
سنشاهد واياكم هذا الفيديو للحظه تحييد
الامن الفرنسي لمنفذ عمليه الطعن في محطه
قطارات جاغدينغ شمال باريس هذا وكان وزير
الداخليه الفرنسيه اعلن ان الحادث الخطير
الذي نفذه شخص شديد التهديد في محطه جاك
الفرنسيه ادى الى اصابه سته اشخاص بينهم
ضابط شرطه
اذن هذه اللحظات تحيه شرطه الامن
للمشتبه به والمتهم بعمليه الطعن في محطه
بالقطارات في فرنسا
كم مشاهد كيف تم القاء القبض على من قام
بطعن سته اشخاص وايضا ضابط شرطه في محطه
القطار طبعا فرنسا تشهد العديد من هكذا
عمليات فرديه بين
الفيناتوال اخرى
[موسيقى]
الى افغانستان
حصيله الهجوم فيما اعلنت الشرطه الافغانيه
سقوط خمسه قتلى بالهجوم افاده متحدث باسم
حركه طالبان مقتل 20 شخص واصابه عدد اخر
في الهجوم الانتحاري وسائل الاعلام
افغانيه قالت لنا الهجوم نفذته انتحاري لم
تحدد هويته بعد
[موسيقى]
بره نائب المتحدث باسم حركات طالبان قرار
الاماره الاسلاميه في افغانستان منع تعليم
المراه في الجامعه بانه من واجبها تنظيم
شؤون التعليم والتنميه في البلاد وفقا
لاحكام الشرع في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه
قال ان النظام طلبان منح المراه حقوقا لم
تكن موجوده في السابق
خير يوقف نظره
الاسلاميه تتكون من علماء وطلاب يهتمون
بالعلوم والتربيه والتعليم اكثر من اي فئه
اخرى والاماره لا تعارض تعليم اي شخص باي
شكل من الاشكال ولكنها مسؤوله عن تنظيم
المراحل التربويه والتعليميه وكل ما يتعلق
بذلك فهي مسؤوله وترى ان من واجبها ان
يكون ذلك وفقا لاحكام الشريعه الاسلاميه
والمبادئ الاسلاميه
قل لا نائب المتحدث باسمي طالبان من اهميه
وجود تنظيم داعش في افغانستان ووصفه
بالظاهره تكفيريه غير المرئيه واكد القضاء
على
98% من اوكار التنظيم مشيرا الى عدم وجود
حاضنه شعبيه له في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
تم القضاء على
98% من عناصر التنظيم وتم تدميره ولكن من
المؤسف ان بعض الدوائر تدعمه من خلال
الاعلام او تموله الاستغلاله ولكن في
الممارسه العمليه ما نراه في الواقع
الميداني لبلدنا هذه الظاهره لا تشكل
تحديا كبيرا وليست مصدرا قلق جاد للامن
الداخلي في بلادنا ولا يمكنه ان يشكل
تهديدا من افغانستان الى دول اخرى
ما قدر عشره وقدر تشيزي قرار النبي
مهما لكي نحتاج الى دول اخرى لمواجهته
داعش ليس تنظيما قويا وليسا مهما ليتمكن
من تجنيد الاشخاص عندنا وليس له مناطق
ثابته فحيث نجد نشاطا تخريبيا منفردا
تطارده قوات الدوله ومخابره الاماره
الاسلاميه ويتم تدميره
لنائب المتحدث باسم طالبان بلال كريمي
الخميس في السادس عشر همم بتوقيت جرينتش
السابعه مساء بتوقيت السعوديه على العربيه
ادري مريض بعد بكره يمكن القول في هذا
الخصوص ان ظاهره داعش تكفيريه ليس لها
وجود مادي ومرئي وملموس في بلادنا فبعد
مجيء الاماره الاسلاميه تم القضاء على 98
في المئه من عناصر التنظيم وتم تدمير او
تاره ولكن من المؤسف ان بعض الدوائر تدعمه
من خلال الاعلام او تموله الاستغلاله ولكن
في الممارسه العمل
الشرطه قريه اا قريه في غرب البلاد سعيا
لاجلاء نشاطاء يسوعنا لوقف اعاده تشغيل
منجم فحم هناك بعد قرار توسيع استخراج
الفحم من المنطقه ومن ما ادى لصدمات بين
الطرفين
[موسيقى]
شهدات هوليود امس الثلاثاء حفل توزيع
جوائز جولدن جو جلوبس 2023 الذي يعد اول
حفل توزيع جوائز كبير خلال هذا الموسم
نتعرف على ابرز الجوائز
[موسيقى]
ابرز الجوائز جولدن 2013
افضل ممثله في فيلم درامي كيت بلانشيت عن
دورها في فيلم تار
افضل ممثل في فيلم جامي اوستن باتلر عن
دوره في فيلم الفاس افضل مخرج فيلم
مسلسل
[موسيقى]
افضل ممثلين في مسلسل الجامي
عن دوري
[موسيقى]
العربيه مستمره كما كل ليله وبالختام
تسكير بابرز العناوين
السلطات الامريكيه تستبعد فرضيه الهجوم
السيبراني بعد اكبر توقف لحركه الطيران في
البلاد
على واقع الشداد المعارك في سوليدار موسكو
تغير قائد عملياتها واوروبا طويله الامل
[موسيقى]
طهران تحكم باعدام مسؤول عسكري بتهمه
التجسس البريطانيا والاخيره تطالبها
بالتراجع والافراج عنه فورا
الجنيه المصري يقلص خسائره